It's the season of giving.
For Kazi Mannan, this means going into overdrive.
Kazi is an immigrant from Pakistan, who now
owns a small but successful restaurant in
downtown Washington DC.
All of these scarves and warm clothes that
he purchased are about to be given away.
This is an annual gathering at Franklin Square
park, in downtown DC, where various charities
and churches will give away food and goods
to people in need just before Christmas.
Kazi has been coming for the past four years,
ever since he opened his restaurant, and has
built up a small network of homeless people
who know him.
"It's a joy, anything that you can make another
person happy...if you can put a smile on someone
else's face, it's a big blessing."
Kazi said he also knows the sting of being
poor.
The restaurant he now owns, serves free meals
to homeless people all day, every day.
"Homelessness is endemic in Washington DC.
One estimate said 11,000 people have to sleep
on the streets every night.
Kazi Mannan himself said that he has experienced
a similar situation of extreme poverty.
And now that he's a successful business owner,
he wants to give back."
Sakina Grill now has a many regular non-paying
customers.
Besides the benefit of freshly made food,
one man told us, it helps him simply feel
accepted.
"It makes you feel regular, like normal...it
kind of makes you feel privileged too."
Kazi's generosity started when the restaurant
started on day one.
Seeing homeless people digging through trash
cans broke his heart, he said.
"I promised that if I ever had a restaurant,
I would have this philosophy...it
will benefit me, and will benefit others."
Over the past four years, Sakina Grill is
still operational, and has given out more
than 80,000 meals.
A good reminder that need knows no season.